vous avez demandé s'il était légal
d'afficher le mot érable ou à l'érable
sur des produits qui ne contiennent que
des arômes naturels ou artificiels
d'érable les réglementations fédérales
et provinciales sont assez souples son
usage du mot par exemple le mot érable
le seul est accepté pour 6 biscuits car
ils ont un go d'érable est une forme de
feuille d'érable mêmes pratiques
acceptables pour cet assaisonnement pour
poissons à l'érable même s'il ne
contient qu'une saveurs artificielles
quant à l'appellation sirop d'érable et
les strictement encadré ces produits ne
pourrait pas affiché au sirop d'érable
s'il n'en contiennent pas et si vous
avez envie de vous sucrer le bec au
sirop d'érable pourquoi ne pas profiter
de la cabane à sucre c'est maintenant
couvert après deux ans et demi
encourageant nos agriculteurs
[Musique]